warren buffett is generally regarded as
the best investor of all time which is
not surprising given his insane track
history he has managed to achieve an
average annual return of 20.5 since 1965
and while buffett does deserve all the
praise he receives someone that often
doesn't get enough credit is charlie
munger charlie is the vice chairman of
berkshire hathaway and has known buffett
since 1959. buffett says that he knew
that he wasn't going to find another guy
like monger as soon as he met him so
hiring monger was a no-brainer for
buffett since then monger has become
buffett's closest ally and business
partner and together dave shaped
berkshire into what it is today
charlie is now a multi-billionaire
himself thanks to the phenomenal
performance of berkshire hathaway yet
most people have no idea who monger even
is especially in comparison to buffett
so here's how monger became the silent
backbone of berkshire hathaway
taking a look back charles thomas monger
was born on january 1 1924 in omaha
nebraska monger had a pretty nice
childhood as he came from a pretty wild
family monger's grandfather himself was
a district court judge and a state
representative meanwhile monger's father
was a lawyer considering this background
i don't think you'd be surprised here
that monger would eventually end up
pursuing a law degree but as a teenager
monger would find himself working at a
local grocery store named buffett and
son as you would guess this door was
owned by buffett's grandfather and this
was monger's first introduction to the
family monger would go on to attend the
university of michigan where he matured
in mathematics but just as he enrolled
pearl harbor would be bombed resulting
in manga dropping out of college and
enlisting in the u.s army corps which
would eventually become the air force
while this was quite a turn of events it
wasn't all bad for monger he would soon
be stationed in alaska where he met a
woman named nancy hoggins who would soon
become his wife apart from this however
wenger found little joy in the air force
he was nominated by all the death and
destruction that he saw on a daily basis
one of the few things that kept him sane
during this time period was playing
cards with his colleagues and this is
where he learned many of the principles
that he would later apply to investing
monger says that cards taught him to
fold early when the odds are against him
and doubled down when he had the edge
playing cards also taught him that
opportunity does not come often which
makes it especially important to seize
opportunity when it does come anyway the
war would finally come to an end in 1945
and monger would leave the military
shortly after by this point wanker
didn't want to go back and finish his
bachelor's but he did want to pursue a
law degree
fortunately the gi bill would help
monger do exactly this he went ahead and
took a bunch of advanced courses at
caltech and he would leverage this
experience to sneak his way into harvard
law school without a bachelor's despite
not having a bachelor's law school was a
breeze from mongura as he would end up
graduating magna [ __ ] laude in 1948 and
with that monger was officially a lawyer
after graduation monger and his new
family would move to california where he
found a job at a law firm called wright
and garrett for most people this would
be the pinnacle of life as monger had
secured a solid job and family but it
wouldn't take long for everything to
unravel
after eight years of marriage and three
children mongre and nancy would decide
to split ways which was not only
challenging emotionally but also
financially monger would end up losing
most of his money and his house to the
divorce and the monger would end up
spending the next few years simply
working back to where he was to make
things worse divorce was heavily
stigmatized at the time which did not
earn monger much respect from his peers
and just when you think that things
can't get worse they got way worse
monger's son teddy would be diagnosed
with leukemia monger didn't have health
insurance so he not only had to pay for
all of the treatment out of pocket but
he had to slowly watch his son get
weaker and weaker for 11 months before
passing away at age 9. around the same
time monger's father would also pass
away which forced monger to return home
and support his family for some time the
one good thing that came out of this
visit was that he would end up meeting a
man named warren buffett the two would
quickly become friends and exchange
contact info but both of them would
return to their own lives after the
visit was over after returning to
california monger would eventually
develop cataracts which forced him to
get surgery in his left eye
unfortunately the surgery would go wrong
which left him blind in his left eye he
held onto the blind eye for some time
but he eventually got his surgically
removed due to severe pain to make
things worse doctors told him that blood
would eventually fill up his right eye
as well which would make him completely
blind so monger would actually begin
learning braille but thankfully monger
would finally catch a break and the
condition would slowly recede clearly
monger had quite a difficult life
throughout his 30s and 40s but here's
what monger had to say about it you do
not want to drift into self-pity
self-pity will not improve the situation
before returning to nebraska for his
father's death bunker would actually
find a second wife ironically her name
was also nancy but this marriage would
end up working far better than the first
despite it being unorthodox for the time
both monger and nancy had two children
each from their previous marriages and
together they would form a new family of
six
these two would end up staying together
for the next 54 years until nancy passed
away in 2010 anyway after his father's
death monger decided to start fresh by
launching his own business in 1962. this
new business was called mongur tools and
olsen and it provided real estate
attorney services while his day job was
still being a lawyer manga spent most of
his free time meddling with the stock
market he had his ups and downs and the
income wasn't super consistent but
monger saw opportunity in the stock
market and he didn't waste time seizing
it soon enough he left law altogether
and partnered with jack wheeler to
launch an investment firm called the
wheeler monger and company at first
monger saw a significant amount of
success
for years he was averaging 20 annual
returns which was four times higher than
the market at the time but the 1970s
would bring with it a lot of pain not
just for monger but for all investors in
general in 1971 president nixon would
drop the gold standard which sent
inflation to the moon and stocks to rock
bottom the s p 500 would face multiple
bear markets throughout this decade and
stocks would basically make no progress
monger was by no means immune to this
market downturn and his investments
would get crushed in 1973 monger would
lose 32 percent and in 1974 he would
lose another 31 percent fortunately the
stock market had a massive rebound in
1975 which allowed monger to post a 73.2
return monger took this as a signal that
he should leave while he still could and
he would close up wheeler manga and
company in 1976 and that marks the end
of monger's days of running his own
business a few years later in 1978
monger would join buffett's company as
vice chairman and the rest is history
while monger technically always worked
under buffett on paper buffett never
treated him as an employee rather
buffett always treated monger as a
business partner in 1984 monger was made
the ceo and chairman of west coast
financial which was a company that
berkshire hathaway had a majority stake
in and this is where monger would spend
most of his time at berkshire roscoe
financial was primarily an insurance
company but monger was allowed to
operate west coast financial as a sort
of mini berkshire hathaway through wesco
munger had the opportunity to invest in
companies like coca-cola craft foods
parker and gamble and wells fargo this
was perfect for monger because west
coast was headquartered in pasadena
california which had been munger's home
for most of his adult life he served as
the ceo and chairman of west coast up
until 2011 when buffett would purchase
the remaining portion of west coast and
integrated completely into berkshire
aside from his role at wescoa monger was
also the chairman of the daily journal
which was yet another berkshire hathaway
business as the name suggests the daily
journal was a publishing company but
news publishing was never mongo's top
priority rather monger primarily focused
on acquiring other publishing companies
and investing companies profits
especially into china mangu is actually
a massive fan of china and alibaba was
one of the diligent biggest investments
as you would guess monger is not a big
fan of the conflict between the us and
china whatsoever he says that they
should like us and we should like them
nonetheless due to the strain between
the us and china over the past few years
manga has reluctantly reduced his
alibaba position significantly this was
one of the last things he did before
stepping down from the daily journal a
few months ago moving on to monger's
final major responsibility we have his
role at costco mangrove became a
director at costco in 1997 around the
time that berkshire invested into the
company berkshire exited their position
in costco in 2020 but monger still
personally owns 81 million worth of
costco stock monger is a massive fan of
costco's business model and he thinks
that the company has a great culture and
ethics he doesn't necessarily think that
costco is a value buy at today's prices
but he also doesn't see a reason to sell
out and that brings us to where we are
today
like buffett monger has turned much of
his focus onto philanthropic activities
one of his biggest contributions has
been to universities for example he was
a massive donor to the university of
michigan he also donated hundreds of
millions to uc santa barbara something
that we should note however is that
monger has not signed the giving pledge
and he has actually been super
transparent about this
he says that he's already given too much
of his money to his children to take any
credit for joining the giving pledge
this has parked some criticism against
monger but honestly it's his money and
he should be able to do whatever he
wants with it something else that
sparked a lot of controversy is munger's
position on bitcoin he has claimed that
bitcoin is disgusting and contrary to
the interest of civilization he has also
called bitcoin rat poison his biggest
critiques against crypto are that he has
no fundamental value and that it
produces no cash flow [ __ ] and buffett
aren't big fans of gold either so it's
not surprising that they don't bind to
bitcoin another sector in which monger
has missed out on is growth stocks and
especially tech stocks berkshire never
really invested into any of the fan
companies except for apple and even
there they relate to the party but the
cool thing is that monger and buffett
have managed to still roughly match the
s p 500 despite missing out on tech
companies it looks like they've chosen
to stick to what they know it and this
strategy has played out extremely well
for them also i'm not sure how much
either of them even care about being a
market anymore in the first place buffet
has already said that berkshire is 100
prepared for his death and i assume that
this applies to monger as well given
that he's 98 years old
though both of them are nearing the end
of their lives there's no doubt that
they'll be remembered as a legendary
investment duo for generations to come
would you guys invest in berkshire
hathaway today comment that down below
also drop a like if you agree that
monger is underrated and of course
consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you